[Music]
you
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
uh we are aware of the current situation
there has been increased military
activity including this morning
um until very
recently a few minutes ago i have been
briefed by the ukrainian regional
military
commander
here about that and the inherent risks
but weighing the pros and cons
and having come so far we are not
stopping we are moving now we know that
there is a
an area as you know the so-called gray
zone where the last line of the
ukrainian defense comes and before the
first line of the russian
occupying forces begin
where the risks are significant
at the same time
we consider that we have the minimum
conditions to move
accepting that the risks are very very
high
still
myself and the team
we believe that we we can proceed with
this we have a very important mission to
accomplish as you know we are going to
start immediately
an assessment
of the security and the safety situation
at the plant as it as it is
right now
we are going to be
liaising and consulting with the staff
at the facility
and i am going to consider the
possibility of establishing a continued
presence
of the iaea at the plant which we
believe it's indispensable to stabilize
the situation and to get regular
reliable impartial neutral updates of
what the situation is there so wish us
luck we are moving now thank you for
your interest it's very important that
the world knows
what's happening here